THOSE ARE SOME IDEAS IF THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY NEED TO PICK UP
IN UNCERTAIN TIMES.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
THE CONGRESSIONAL RESPONSE TO
THE VIRUS MUCH DEBATE ON
CAPITOL HILL ABOUT THE WAY
FORWARD, JOINING US THIS EVENING
NEW YORK DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, THANKS
FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Bret: WHAT’S YOUR CONCERN,
WHAT YOU THINK CONGRESS WILL DO?
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW
ARE A LOT OF DRAMATIC
DEVELOPMENTS THIS WEEK IN
RESPONSE TO THE CORONAVIRUS BOTH
WITH OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND OUR
ECONOMIC RESPONSE.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS ACT
SWIFTLY TO NOT JUST CONCENTRATE
ON SOLUTIONS FOR WALL STREET, WE
NEED TO PROVIDE RELIEF FOR
WORKING AMERICANS, AMERICANS
WERE LIVING OFF OF TIPS AND
GETTING LAID OFF, WHOSE SHIFTS
ARE BEING CANCELED ALL OF A
SUDDEN AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ACT VERY QUICKLY.
THAT’S WHY I THINK IT’S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE PASS THE BILL
THAT HAS BEEN PRESENTED TODAY
WHICH INCLUDES PAID SICK LEAVE,
IT INCLUDES EXTENDED
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS,
PROTECTIONS FOR MEDICAID AND
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
TAKING ACTION TO PROTECT DOCTORS
AND NURSES AND HOSPITAL WORKERS
ON THE FRONT LINES.
>> Bret: THERE’S BEEN SOME
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
SPEAKER PELOSI AND TREASURY
SECRETARY MNUCHIN, THERE IS
ABOUT WHAT THE SENATE WILL DO OR
WANT TO WITH THE HOUSE BILL --
THE PAYROLL TAX HOLIDAY NEVER
REALLY TOOK OFF, YOU WERE THERE
AT THE TIME BUT THEY WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF IT UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA, IT DOESN’T WORK
THIS TIME?
>> WHAT WE NEED TO SEE IS WHAT
TOOLS WE USE FOR WHAT RESPONSES.
A PAYROLL TAX IS ONE THING TO BE
CONSIDERED WHEN THERE ARE
CERTAIN ECONOMIC INDICATORS BUT
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH IS A PANDEMIC.
WHEN WE NEED TO DO IS MAKE SURE
WE ARE TAKING SWIFT ACTIONS
RIGHT NOW TO PROTECT DOCTORS AND
PEOPLE ON MEDICAID, TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE CAN SEE A DOCTOR AND
THOSE OF THE THINGS WE NEED TO
BE FOCUSED ON ON RIGHT NOW.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT A PAYROLL TAX
LATER, DEBATE ALL OF THESE
THINGS AT ANOTHER TIME BUT RIGHT
NOW IS A MOMENT FOR SWIFT ACTION
TO MAKE SURE WE ARE PROTECTING
OUR ELDERS AND IMMUNOCOMPROMISED
AMERICANS.
>> Bret: I WANT TO PLAY WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID YESTERDAY
ABOUT POLITICS.
>> WE HAVE THE BEST ECONOMY, THE
MOST ADVANCED HEALTH CARE, AND
THE MOST TALENTED DOCTORS,
SCIENTISTS, AND RESEARCHERS
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
WE ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
WE MUST PUT POLITICS ASIDE, STOP
THE PARTISANSHIP, AND UNIFY
TOGETHER AS ONE NATION AND ONE
FAMILY.
>> Bret: AGREE WITH THAT?
>> ONE THING WE NEED TO DO IS
PUT POLITICS ASIDE AND THAT’S
EXACTLY WHAT DEMOCRATS HAVE
AGREED WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
HIS GOALS OF PAID SICK LEAVE AND
HIS GOALS OF FREE CORONAVIRUS
TESTING.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN OUR PACKAGE, WE PUMP
IT UP A LITTLE BIT MORE BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE A DEMOCRATIC HOUSE AND
REPUBLICAN SENATE, COMPROMISES
THE NAME OF THE GAME.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO HAVE
TO ACCEPT THE FACT WE ARE
FIGHTING FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE POTENTIALLY
UNEMPLOYED, HE’S GOING TO HAVE
TO ACCEPT THE FACT WE ARE GOING
TO PUSH ON DOCTOR AND NURSE
PROTECTION.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BEST
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IN THE WORLD,
THAT’S SOMETHING THAT’S UP FOR
DEBATE.
SOUTH KOREA HAS 10,000 TESTS PER
DAY, THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE TESTS TO ANY SINGLE
PERSON WHO WANTS IT AND HERE,
PEOPLE ARE SCRAMBLING.
IT ALMOST SEEMS LIKE THE MORE
WEALTHY AND POWERFUL YOU ARE,
THE MORE ABLE YOU ARE TO ACCESS
A TEST, BUT THE MORE -- THE
ROUGHER ROAD YOU GOT HERE, IT’S
GOING TO BE A LOT MORE DIFFICULT
TO ACCESS HEALTH CARE.
THAT IS EXACTLY THE RECIPE FOR
DISASTER IN A PANDEMIC.
>> Bret: DR. FAUCI TESTIFIED
AS A FAILING ON TESTING ON
CAPITOL HILL BUT ON THE POLITICS
FRONT, IT WAS ONLY TWO WEEKS AGO
YOU TWEETED OUT MIKE PENCE
LITERALLY DID NOT BELIEVE IN
SCIENCE, IT’S IRRESPONSIBLE TO
PUT HIM IN CHARGE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE AS THE
WORLD SITS ON THE CUSP OF A
PANDEMIC, THIS DECISION COULD
COST PEOPLE THEIR LIVES.
OBVIOUSLY VICE PRESIDENT PENCE
IS THE HEAD OF THE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE WITH DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI, THE HEAD OF THE CDC, ALL
OF THIS OTHER SIDE TESTS WERE A
PART OF IT, ISN’T THAT POLITICS?
>> I DISAGREE WITH THE
APPOINTMENT OF
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, I’VE MADE
THAT EXTRAORDINARILY CLEAR BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY, HE’S
THERE.
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE ACTIONS
THAT ARE HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND
THE ACTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
HAPPENING IS MAKING SURE WE ARE
TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE HURTING AS A RESULT
OF THIS.
THIS IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
BUT IT’S ALSO AN ECONOMIC CRISIS
AND ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH FRONT,
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
OLDER AND IMMUNOCOMPROMISED IN
COUNTRY AND THE CORONAVIRUS HAS
BEEN TESTIFIED FROM THE CDC
DIRECTOR AS IT TEN TIMES MORE
LETHAL THAN THE FLU.
>> Bret: PEOPLE POINT TO THE
H1N1 VIRUS AND IT KILLED A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THE U.S. AND THERE
IS A WONDER WHERE THE PERFECT
RESPONSE IS -- WHETHER WE GO TOO
FAR, WHAT IF WE DON’T GO FAR
ENOUGH.
YOU’RE SAYING WE SHOULD NOT
WORRY ABOUT THAT NOW.
>> I DON’T THINK WE SHOULD WORRY
ABOUT IT RIGHT NOW.
ONE THING THAT I WILL AGREE WITH
IS THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE
PANICKING BUT WE SHOULD BE
PREPARING.
IF WE ARE AT A STANDSTILL HERE
IN WASHINGTON AND WE AREN’T
GETTING THESE THINGS PASSED AND
WE AREN’T WILLING TO COMPROMISE
AND NEGOTIATE FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
GOING TO BE UNEMPLOYED AND FOLKS
WHO NEED THESE HOSPITALS AND
FOLKS WHO ARE ON, THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE HURT
BY THIS.
WE HAVE TO DEPOLITICIZE THAT,
RIGHT NOW WE’RE HEARING SOME OF
THE FIGHTS AND GRIDLOCK ARE
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE TRY TO PUT
PRO-LIFE POSITIONS INTO THIS.
WE CAN HAVE THAT DEBATE ANOTHER
TIME, WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE
DISAGREE ON IT.
>> Bret: DEMOCRATS TRY TO ADD
STUFF TRUE, IT BECOMES A
CHRISTMAS TREE WHEN BIG BILLS
ARE PASSED.
TO YOUR POINT, I WANT TO ASK A
COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
YOU ARE BERNIE SANDERS MOST
PROMINENT SURROGATE, WAS IT
DIFFICULT TO WITNESS HIS SWIFT
FAULT FROM FRONT RUNNER STATUS.
HE IS ALMOST A PROTEST CANDIDATE
NOW, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE SAW
WITH BERNIE SANDERS LEADERSHIP,
EVEN TODAY IS HOW TRANSFORMATIVE
IT IS FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
JUST TODAY HE LAID OUT A VERY
STRONG PLAN IN RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS ARE EVERYDAY PEOPLE,
FOR MAIN STREET, NOT JUST
WALL STREET.
HE’S TALKING ABOUT HOW DOES DO W
MAKE SURE EVERYONE WITH ACCESS
TO MEDICARE COULD GET IT, HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE PEOPLE AREN’T
BOOTED OUT OF THEIR HOMES WHERE
THERE IS NOT BEING ABLE TO
AFFORD THE MORTGAGE PAYMENT THIS
MONTH.
>> Bret: IT SEEMS LIKE
JOE BIDEN IS ON HIS WAY TO THE
NOMINATION, ARE YOU WORRIED HE’S
NOT GOING TO BE SAYING THOSE
THINGS?
>> THIS PART OF OUR PROCESS IS
TO MAKE SURE WE COME TOGETHER, I
THINK THERE’S GOING TO BE A REAL
VIGOROUS DEBATE I BELIEVE ON
SUNDAY NIGHT IF I’M NOT MISTAKEN
AND PART OF THAT PROCESS MEANS I
THINK WE WILL COME TOGETHER AND
I THINK BERNIE SANDERS HAS DONE
A GREAT JOB AND IS CONTINUING TO
DO A GREAT JOB OF PUSHING TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A PARTY AGENDA
THAT FIGHTS FOR WORKING PEOPLE.
>> Bret: YOU DID A CAMPAIGN
EVENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
MICHIGAN, 10,000 PEOPLE, IT WAS
ROCK STAR STATUS BUT THOSE KIDS
DID NOT SHOW UP AT LEAST IF YOU
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS, OVERALL.
THIS RACE.
HOW CAN YOU SAY THE PROGRESSIVE
POSITION IS STILL PREVAILING
NATIONWIDE WHEN JOE BIDEN IS
WINNING SO MUCH?
>> I THINK ONE THING THAT ISN’T
BEING TALKED ABOUT IS THAT
RAMPANT VOTER SUPPRESSION IN
THIS COUNTRY.
RIGHT THERE IN ANN ARBOR WHERE
WE HAD THAT RALLY, THOSE KIDS
WERE WAITING THREE HOURS IN LINE
TO VOTE IN MICHIGAN.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHO’S TURNING
OUT AND WHO’S NOT TURNING OUT --
>> Bret: YOU THINK VOTERS
DIDN’T GET TO VOTE WHO WANTED TO
VOTE IN MICHIGAN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE’S MORE THAT WE NEED TO DO
IN TERMS OF TURNING OUT YOUTH
VOTERS, WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE INSPIRING YOUNG PEOPLE TO
TURN OUT BUT WHEN YOU DO TURN
OUT YOU SHOULD NOT BE WAITING
THREE, FOUR, SEVEN HOURS IN
ORDER TO VOTE.
>> Bret: YOU ARE WORKING
WITHIN THE SYSTEM NOW, YOU
STRUCK SOME CONCILIATORY TONES
TONIGHT AND ON CAPITOL HILL.
AT THE SAME TIME YOU ARE BACKING
PRIMARY CHALLENGES FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP -- JERRY NADLER,
STENY HOYER --
>> THAT’S NOT CORRECT.
I’M NOT BACKING PRIMARY
CHALLENGES FOR THOSE TWO.
>> Bret: A GROWING LIST OF
PRIMARY CHALLENGERS, HAVE YOU
BACKED STENY HOYER, JERRY NADLER
JERRY NADLER?
>> I HAVE BACKED PRIMARY
CHALLENGERS TO DAN LIPINSKI.
>> Bret: HOW DO YOU SWEAR
THAT?
>> I THINK THERE ARE PLACES WE
CAN DO BETTER.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT NOT BEING
PARTISAN.
I THINK REPUBLICANS CAN LOOK IN
THEIR OWN BACKYARD AND SAY THIS
IS WHAT WE CAN DO BETTER.
I THINK DEMOCRATS CAN LOOK IN
OUR OWN BACKYARD AND SAY THAT
THERE ARE PLACES WE CAN DO
BETTER TOO.
I THINK IF YOU ARE TAKING BIG
MONEY AND RELYING ON LOBBYIST
FUNDS AND YOU AREN’T ANSWERING
TO YOUR CONSTITUENTS BACK HOME
TO ME SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
I DON’T THINK INCUMBENCY SHOULD
BE A THING THAT IS GUARANTEED.